lo primero es recapitular que aquí se
esperaba hacer una evaluación de cómo va
la mitad del decenio de la acción por el
agua y también el objetivo de desarrollo
número 6 que tiene que ver con agua y
saneamiento si bien ese reporte no se
conoció sí se recopilaron todos los
insumos y el informe final se presentará
en el foro anual de desarrollo
sostenible que Será en julio próximo
aquí mismo en Nueva York lo que sí
ocurrió fue primero el secretario
general de Naciones Unidas Antonio
Gutiérrez Se comprometió a estudiar el
reiterado llamado por crear la figura de
un enviado especial para el agua dentro
de la ONU lo segundo es que como usted
lo mencionaba hay 708 acuerdos por un
valor de 300.000 millones de dólares
según la ONU y de aquellos 153 Fueron
presentados por gobiernos y lo tercero y
más importante es que el agua quedó en
el centro del debate como lo dijo el
propio Gutiérrez el agua debe ser de
ahora en adelante el eje central tanto
de lo que ocurre en la ONU como de lo
que ocurra en las discusiones políticas
y muy brevemente esta agenda de acción
por el agua que es la que recopila los
compromisos se revisará primero en el
Foro de Julio luego en la Cumbre del
futuro en 2024 Y por último en la Cumbre
social del mundo en 2025